this film manages to cover so many the
big American topics from family dynamics
to class race drug addiction
incarceration masculinity and yet never
with a heavy hand I think that's a quite
quite an accomplishment
I'll start by asking Trey you know I
mean Calvin you had every good choice of
whatever role you wanted here and you
chose the role of Tyler why did you
choose that one well I really I wanted
any sorry I just wanted the most
challenging well in my opinion and you
know he what he told me he was like
there's the brother brother in the first
half was a wrestler and there's the
boyfriend in the second half and it
really just came down to logistics of
just being good and not me being not not
not being an athlete and then from there
it was just discussing the the parallels
between our lives and sharing our
stories about what our relationships
were like with our father and my
romantic relationship so I was really
excited to kind of dive in and explore
what it meant to be a young black male
and in a middle class and which mirrored
my family in a lot of ways and so that
was what really got me into the movie
Trey you guys have worked together
before so what was it like collaborating
on this week because you guys developed
this role together and just some degree
even the role of Ronald yeah was that it
was beautiful best collaboration of my
life well we we did we made a movie
before and that's how we met and we
loved each other and want to make
something together again and at that
point there wasn't you know the broad
strokes for the story were there there
wasn't a title they weren't character
names but it was like the outline and
every and I started talking to Cowell
about it then and then you know we just
like got closer over a year and then
after that movie came out I started
writing and that's why yeah we basically
started having these like mini therapy
sessions we called it where we were just
talking about our past like hell was
saying we're talking about what it felt
like at that age in our relationships
and dynamics and commonalities and
differences and nuances and everything
in between it and so I was basically
writing with just having these
conversations with him and digging in
and everything and then he got a draft
about like eight months or more before
we started shooting and then and then it
just continued and it kept evolving so
like at that point you know we'd go
through it and study it and Kelvin will
over analyze and study everything to
death which I love about him is
incredibly smart and we would just do
that a lot and and we would get to you
know Tyler and his father and the family
and the dynamics and in nuances there
and going over and over and to where now
it feels like yeah I think expecially
Ty's like a combination of that
collaboration and I think if it feels
special and unique that's why you know I
was dazzled by this I mean you're you
know at first it was it's you know it's
dizzying and energetic and and an
intimate and then you then you realize
that it's actually really living the
inner mindset of the character of the
lead character and then in part two it's
a very different very different approach
with with Emily can you talk about that
both from an artistic point of view and
also a technical point of view yeah well
basically everything we're doing with
the filmmaking is just get you closer to
these kids heads you know so like what
you said it we're trying to make their
internal feeling come across with the
colors with the camera movement with the
ratios with the music and really just
trying to make this subjective immersive
experience so if that's a camera
spinning through a car it's because
that's what they're loved in that moment
feels like that's what that freedom at
that age in your car with the person you
love with their relationship their love
is like a bottle of fire you know so
like though to me the only way to
spiritually bring that across is to
literally spend with them and then and
then but then that changes you know and
like if the camera will the camera in
the filmmaking will fluctuate with
whatever's going on with their journey
in their arc in their story and their
emotions so there's short it's crazy
fluid and spinning through a car but
then when Emily is taking over and her
world has just been depth devastated and
falling apart you know we're in four by
three shallow focus long lenses
isolating her from her environment the
camera is not moving at all because
that's how she's feeling and I also want
to give a shout out drew Daniels
he's I think the best in the world and
we made every movie together and yeah
long-winded answer basically we're just
trying to do everything to make it a
very emotional subjective immersive
experience and make it feel like either
you're literally seeing through there
these kids eyes Tyler and Emily or
you're feeling through them or it feels
like if it's just father and daughter on
a bench you're sitting right there next
to them yeah it was amazing I felt the
same way about your your score from turn
wrestler and collaborator Atticus Ross
you guys have done something really
amazing with that can you talk a little
bit about those strategies the the sort
of themes that were put under every
character that went up leaving out
throughout the entire film yeah I mean I
think especially for the score you know
there's a lot of there's a lot of
soundtrack yeah there's a lot of music
and a lot of songs so I was a bit
terrified when I sent a script with like
30 plus songs to Trent Reznor and
Atticus Ross I mean like where do I fit
into this and it was the total opposite
they're really excited and it became
about differentiating that and making it
about sort of again the interior ness of
the characters almost like the
subconscious and the spirit coming out
in connecting and I think especially
between brother and sister you know cuz
it really is their story and they're
rarely together so like they're
connected through the music and these
color interludes and so they did that
with things of like literally taking
sounds from the film and manipulating
them and using them musically to you
know why they pick a piano and piano
themes because Tyler Tyler loves the
piano and like so really just trying to
get across their interior spirit and
this sort of connection and almost the
spirit of the movie and this link that's
happening between the yin and the yang
and the two halves and how that makes it
the whole and I just think the score is
so huge to to all of that coming
together and then Kelvin in terms of
preparing for Tyler beyond the change of
hair color what else what else went on
it was interesting because what I saw in
the script was that we really try really
wanted to explore masculinity and toxic
masculinity and vulnerability and and by
casting me in a young black man
I think Frank really encapsulate s'what
that is you know his music so pure and
so sensitive and so just honest and I
think but Tyler was just like hearing
that and and seeing that I was like this
is this is what is kind of making its
kind of filling him up inside this is
what is inside that he doesn't feel like
he can let out so it's just like I was
just constantly feeling that Center of
so many secrets so many things that's
just bottling up that's just pressing on
him and Frank and you know even for out
did we do you know his new GQ cover
redefining masculinity is so much of
what this boy is in this moment he just
hasn't had the outlet or the space to to
really express that and so um yeah we
really wanted to kind of just to get
into it all I want to thank you guys
both for your comments